It's OK to say this, right? There's a lot of long-term joy to being a parent. But the daily job of it, the mundane feeding your kids and driving them around and disciplining them-- there's not always a lot of pleasure in that.
这样说应该没问题吧？为人父母有着许多长久的快乐。但其中的日常工作，那些琐事，比如喂孩子、开车送他们去这儿去那儿、管教他们——这些过程中并不总是充满乐趣。
Which is why, whenever I've talked to Elna Baker about her parents-- Elna works here at the radio show-- whenever Elna talks about her parents, I've always been so impressed at the happy originality of some of their parenting moves, like the ingenuity that her dad brought to tasks that no parent enjoys.
正因如此，每当我跟埃尔娜·贝克谈起她的父母——埃尔娜就在我们这档广播节目工作——每当埃尔娜提到她的父母，我总是对他们育儿方式中那种快乐的原创性印象深刻，比如她父亲在处理那些没哪个家长会喜欢的任务时，所展现出的独创性。
For instance, let's say he would discover that one of the kids had broken something, or eaten a piece of cake that nobody was supposed to touch. He would gather the kids together.
比如说，假设他发现孩子们中间有谁打破了东西，或者偷吃了谁都不该碰的蛋糕。他会把孩子们召集到一起。
So with five kids, he would ask all of us which one of us had done it, and we would all lie. And so his way of determining who really did it was he would say, line up, tallest to shortest-- he would always make us line up tallest to shortest. I don't know, I think he saw Sound of Music . And if you have five kids, why not?
因为有五个孩子，他会问我们是谁干的，我们都会撒谎。而他判断谁才是真凶的方法是，他说：排好队，从最高到最矮——他总是让我们按从高到矮排队。我不知道，我想他大概是看过《音乐之声》。如果家里有五个孩子，为什么不呢？
Yeah?
是吗？
So we would line up against the wall. And he said, I'm going to do the hot knife. And what he would do is he would take out like a butter knife. And he would hold a match or a lighter underneath it. And he would say stick out your tongues.
所以我们就靠着墙排成一排。他说，我要用“热刀”。他拿出一把黄油刀，在下面点了一根火柴或打火机。然后他说：把舌头伸出来。
And so if you're the liar, it'll burn your tongue, is what was explained to us. You're nervous, and all the saliva on your tongue will dry up.
他解释说，如果你是撒谎者，刀就会烫伤你的舌头。你很紧张，舌头上的唾液会干掉。
But if you're telling the truth--
但如果你说的是实话——
Then you'll have enough moisture on your tongue and it won't burn.
那你的舌头就会保持湿润，就不会被烫伤。
OK, of course, that's ridiculous. What was really happening was, he wouldn't hold the flame close enough to the knife to heat it up at all. So the knife wasn't hot, and then he would put the knife on the tongue of his oldest daughter.
好吧，当然，这很荒谬。实际上发生的情况是，他并没有把火焰靠得离刀太近，根本没加热。所以刀一点都不烫，然后他把刀贴在大女儿的舌头上。
And so she would be the first. And by the time he went to move on to me, the second child, one of us would confess.
她是第一个。等他轮到我这个第二个孩子时，我们中就会有人招认了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
One of us would be like, I did it. I couldn't help it. I'm so sorry.
我们中会有人说，是我干的。我忍不住了。真的非常抱歉。
So Elna's dad definitely tried to do the right thing as a parent. But he didn't mind entertaining himself in the process. And occasionally, he would ad hoc his way to moves that had a secret kind of long-term genius to them that took years to pay off.
所以埃尔娜的父亲作为一名家长，确实努力在做正确的事。但他也不介意在此过程中给自己找点乐子。偶尔，他会即兴想出一些带有长期天才色彩的妙招，只是需要多年时间才能显现出成效。
Like, for example, the day Elna hit her sister on the head with a broom. That day began with Elna's parents sending all five kids out to clean up the garage, which her parents would do now and then.
比如，埃尔娜有次用扫帚打了她妹妹的头。那天开始于埃尔娜的父母让五个孩子去清理车库，这是他们偶尔会做的事。
I think we thought we were doing real cleaning, but mostly they just wanted to spend some alone time with the kids not in the house. They would make up either outdoor chores or the garage.
我想我们当时以为自己在做真正的清洁工作，但其实他们主要是想找点私人时间，不想让孩子在屋里。他们要么会编造出户外杂活，要么就让我们去打扫车库。
Elna's little sister Julia found a pair of skates in the garage and she was just skating around, which annoyed Elna, who was really trying to work and clean the garage. Elna was nine, Julia was five. Elna told Julia to get to work. Elna was ignored, which in her mind was not how things were supposed to go between her and her little sister.
埃尔娜的小妹妹朱莉娅在车库里发现了一双溜冰鞋，就在那儿滑来滑去，这惹恼了正努力打扫车库的埃尔娜。埃尔娜九岁，朱莉娅五岁。埃尔娜叫朱莉娅去干活。朱莉娅无视了她，这在埃尔娜看来，绝不是她和妹妹之间该有的相处方式。
And she got so mad that she took this broom-- and it was one of those big industrial booms with the big, heavy, wide tops-- and she bashed Julia with it, bashed her in the head. Blood pours down Julia's face. Elena suddenly realizes, like, oh my god, this is serious. What did I do?
她气急败坏地拿起了那把扫帚——那种带有巨大、沉重、宽阔扫头的工业扫帚——狠狠地砸向朱莉娅，砸在了她的头上。鲜血顺着朱莉娅的脸流了下来。埃尔娜突然意识到，天哪，这事儿严重了。我做了什么？
It wasn't like a line-- it was like a stream of blood came running down her head. And I genuinely thought I had maybe, accidentally killed my sister.
那不是一道痕迹，而是一股血流顺着她的头流了下来。我当时真的以为我可能不小心把妹妹杀死了。
Julia runs to their dad, who administers first aid.
朱莉娅跑向他们的父亲，父亲为她进行了急救。
And I remember just watching from the corner of the bathroom, just towels of blood from the top of her head.
我记得我当时躲在浴室角落里看着，满是鲜血的毛巾从她头顶拿下来。
Once the bleeding stops, and Julia's bandaged up, Elna's dad comes out into the hallway, and he asks Elna, what happened? Elna knows how much trouble she would be in if she admitted the truth, so she lies. She says it was an accident-- the broom slipped.
血止住后，朱莉娅包扎好了，埃尔娜的父亲来到走廊，问埃尔娜发生了什么事。埃尔娜知道如果承认真相会惹多大麻烦，于是她撒谎了。她说是个意外——扫帚滑了一下。
I remember him saying, are you sure that's what happened? And I said yes.
我记得他说，你确定是这样吗？我说确定。
Julia, of course, had told him what really happened-- that Elna walloped her intentionally. And now Elena's dad was in the annoying situation that parents find themselves in now and then. One child says it happened one way, one says the opposite. And he gets an idea.
当然，朱莉娅已经告诉了他真相——埃尔娜是故意狠狠揍了她。现在埃尔娜的父亲陷入了家长们偶尔会遇到的那种烦人处境。一个孩子说是一种情况，另一个说完全相反。然后他想到了一个主意。
So he brought everyone in. We all sat on my parents' bed. And he proceeded to conduct a family trial, where each child had to give their testimony of the events in the garage.
于是他把所有人都叫了进去。我们都坐在父母的床上。他开始主持一场家庭审判，让每个孩子都要陈述在车库里发生的事。
And he videotaped this?
他还录像了？
Yes.
是的。
That's right. There's video of this. They had just gotten their first video camera. And her dad thought, oh, maybe this is the kind of thing you use this for. Or who knows, maybe he just thought the camera added gravitas to the proceedings.
没错。有这段录像。他们当时刚买了第一台摄像机。她父亲想，噢，也许这就是这种东西的用途。或者谁知道呢，也许他只是觉得摄像机增加了审讯的严肃感。
We were cleaning outside, and I was [INAUDIBLE].
我们在外面打扫，我当时……[听不清]。
OK, so there's this shot here of your little sister. She looks like she's been crying, and she's about to burst into tears more any second. Like, her eyes are big and wide and watery.
好的，画面里有你小妹妹的镜头。她看起来刚哭过，随时都可能又要大哭一场。她的眼睛睁得大大的，眼眶湿润。
Her hair is wet from the blood, and she has a bandage in the center of her head.
她的头发被血弄湿了，头顶中间贴着一块绷带。
The bandage is like a comic prop. It's just a Band-Aid, a regular Band-Aid, stuck to her hair.
那块绷带就像滑稽道具。那只是个创可贴，普通的创可贴，粘在头发上。
And then Elna holded the handle up high, and then it went down.
然后埃尔娜把柄举得很高，然后它就掉下来了。
So was it Elna's fault?
所以是埃尔娜的错吗？
Yes.
是的。
She did it on purpose?
她是故意的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
OK, Elna, what's your story?
好的，埃尔娜，你的版本是什么？
I just told you. Well, I didn't do that on purpose. I was just holding it.
我刚才已经说了。嗯，我不是故意的。我只是拿着它而已。
All right. Now I just want to describe the way you look in this. First of all, you have a huge smile on your face.
好了。现在我想描述一下你在这段录像里的样子。首先，你脸上挂着一个巨大的微笑。
Yeah. I'm trying to play it super casual.
是的。我当时正努力装得非常随意。
I asked Julia to come and help me get all the stuff out of the thingamajigger. And then she accidentally got hit with the broom, the side of it--
我叫朱莉娅来帮我把杂物从那个玩意儿里拿出来。然后她不小心被扫帚扫到了，扫帚侧面——
I'm just going to note that you never meet your dad's eye, you never look up at the camera, you're totally avoiding everyone's gaze.
我要指出的是，你始终没有看向父亲的眼睛，也没有看镜头，你完全是在回避所有人的目光。
And she started crying, and I went over by the car and I said, it's all right. You're going to be OK. And I hugged her and I looked at her head, and I took her inside, and dad fixed her all up.
然后她开始哭，我走过去靠在车边说，没事的。你会没事的。我抱了她，看了看她的头，然后把她带进屋，爸爸就给她处理好了。
Elna's dad pulls the other kids as witnesses. Elna's older sister didn't actually see anything, but concludes in the testimony that Elna probably did not mean to hit Julia so hard, but probably did hit her, which actually seems like the truth of the situation.
埃尔娜的父亲叫来其他孩子作证。埃尔娜的姐姐其实没看见什么，但在证词中总结说埃尔娜可能并不是故意打那么重，但很可能确实打了她，这看起来似乎就是事实真相。
Elna's dad turns back to Elna after each bit of testimony, and Elna's voice gets higher and higher as she holds on to her lie.
每次听完证词，埃尔娜的父亲都转回身问埃尔娜，而埃尔娜的声音因为坚持撒谎而变得越来越尖。
And the broom accidentally slipped, and it accidentally hit her on the head, and I didn't do that on purpose.
扫帚不小心滑了，不小心打到了她的头，我不是故意的。
Can I just say, if there are any little kids listening to the program today-- seriously, learn from this. Listen to how high Elna's voice gets when she says, no, I didn't.
我能说一句吗，如果今天节目有小孩子在听——认真点，从中学到教训。听听埃尔娜在说“不，我没有”时声音有多高。
Do you believe she did it on purpose?
你相信她是故意的吗？
She did it on purpose.
她是故意的。
I didn't.
我没有。
The dad moves into the sentencing part of the trial, asks Julia what punishment would be fair. Julia thinks spanking. And it feels like that is where this is headed. Elna's dad turns to her mom to administer the punishment, and then her mom just turns everything upside down when she says--
父亲进入了审判的判决环节，问朱莉娅什么样的惩罚才公平。朱莉娅觉得应该打屁股。感觉事情就要往那方向发展了。埃尔娜的父亲转向母亲去执行惩罚，然后母亲的一句话让一切峰回路转——
I'm not convinced that it was on purpose.
我不相信她是故意的。
Oh, you're not?
噢，不相信吗？
No, because if you think about it--
不，因为如果你仔细想的话——
She says, the way Elna was holding the broom, it really could have been an accident. It's stupid to hold a broom with the heavy part in the  air, she says.
她说，以埃尔娜拿扫帚的方式，那确实可能是个意外。她说，拿着重的一头举在空中是很蠢的。
So the only thing Elna's guilty of is stupidity?
所以埃尔娜唯一的罪过就是愚蠢？
Yeah.
是的。
Elna, what do you think of that?
埃尔娜，你觉得呢？
It pans from my mom to me, and you see that I've just taken in that I might get off. And I have this-- I go from this moment of where I was just almost crying, and I have this really mischievous smile on my face and I say, I guess I'm stupid.
镜头从我妈妈转向我，你可以看到我意识到自己可能逃脱惩罚后的表情。我从刚才那个几乎要哭的状态，脸上露出了一种非常顽皮的笑容，我说，我想我是挺蠢的。
I guess I'm stupid.
我想我是挺蠢的。
And with that, she gets off. No spanking, no consequences. And then, Elna says, a funny thing happened. It just stuck with her. Wouldn't go away.
就这样，她脱身了。没有打屁股，没有任何后果。然后，埃尔娜说，一件有趣的事情发生了。它一直困扰着她，挥之不去。
I thought about it way more than if I'd just been spanked. I carried the guilt of this for most of my childhood. Like in church, when they would talk about lying or sin, this is the thing I would hold onto and relive, because it was the worst thing I'd ever done.
我思考它的次数比直接挨打要多得多。我在整个童年时期都背负着这种愧疚感。比如在教堂里，当他们谈论谎言或罪恶时，我就会想到并重温这件事，因为这是我做过的最糟糕的事。
And then also feeling so much worse because I'd then lied about it, and gotten away with it.
而且因为我后来撒了谎并且逃脱了惩罚，心里更难受了。
Did you also worry that after you died that was going to keep you out of heaven?
你有没有担心过，死后这会让你进不了天堂？
Yeah, I did. Like I thought a part of me was evil because I was capable of doing it.
是的，我担心过。我觉得自己有一部分是邪恶的，因为我竟然做得出来。
Doing it of lying, she means. Of tricking her parents. It was a scheming, selfish part of her that seemed worse than just hitting her sister.
“做得出来”，她是说撒谎这件事。欺骗父母这件事。那是她身上邪恶、自私的一面，这看起来比仅仅打了妹妹更严重。
And I was afraid of that part of me, because I got away with it.
我害怕我身上的那一部分，因为我逃脱了惩罚。
And then do you think it kept you from hitting her more?
那你觉得这是否让你没有再打她了？
Yeah, I never hit her again. I would want to hit her. I would clench my fist and make this face, but I never hit her.
是的，我再也没打过她。我想过要打她。我会握紧拳头，做出那种表情，但我从没打过她。
Not that she stopped being mean. She was still so mean to her sister. She told Julia she was stupid. She said mean things in front of her friends. She trained the baby in the family, Jill, to start crying if Julia ever picked up.
并不是说她不再刻薄了。她对妹妹依然很刻薄。她对朱莉娅说她很蠢。她在朋友面前说刻薄的话。她甚至教家里的幼子吉尔，只要朱莉娅一抱他，就开始大哭。
But Elna grew up remembering the trial. She did not remember it was videotaped, though. Then nearly 20 years after the event, her brother found the video in some old boxes. And they popped it in and they watched it together, as a family, with her parents and everybody.
但埃尔娜长大后一直记着那次审判。不过，她当时并不知道过程被录了下来。近20年后，她哥哥在旧箱子里发现了录像带。全家人坐在一起看了，包括她父母。
And to Elna's surprise-- OK, she thought, back when she was nine, she thought she was like a criminal mastermind or something to put this lie over on both of her parents.
令埃尔娜惊讶的是——好吧，她当时九岁时，以为自己是个犯罪天才，能骗过父母双方。
And you watch it now as an adult, and I just think watching me, how could you possibly believe me? I'm so obviously lying. Obviously, I'm guilty. And I say to my dad, how on earth did you not think that I was guilty?
而当你现在作为一个成年人去看它时，我看着当时的自己，觉得怎么可能相信我？我撒谎撒得太明显了。显然我有罪。我问父亲，你怎么可能一点都不觉得我有罪？
And his response was, I knew you were guilty the second you walked in the house.
他的回答是，你进屋的那一秒我就知道你有罪。
I knew that she did it. You could just see her eyes just shifting back and forth, so you knew, or I knew, she's a little liar.
我知道是她干的。你可以看到她的眼睛不停地左右闪烁，所以我知道，我知道，她是个小骗子。
This, of course, is Elna's dad, Gary Baker. He told me that after she lied to him at the very beginning, he staged the trial, expecting that she would cave, she would do the right thing, she would tell the truth. And then she didn't.
这就是埃尔娜的父亲，加里·贝克。他告诉我，在他最初审问时她撒谎后，他策划了那场审判，期望她会崩溃，会做正确的事，会说实话。但她没有。
Her mom, by the way, told me she also was not convinced by Elna. She tried to push the idea that it was an accident for Julia's sake, so Julia wouldn't be so scared of Elna going forward.
顺便说一下，她母亲告诉我，她当时也没被埃尔娜说服。她尝试提出意外的论点是为了朱莉娅好，这样朱莉娅以后就不会那么怕埃尔娜。
But once she raised the possibility of not punishing Elna, her dad grabbed at the idea, and just made a judgment on the fly that that would be a more effective punishment for Elna, given Elna's personality.
但一旦她提出了不惩罚埃尔娜的可能性，她父亲就抓住了这个点，临时做出了决定，考虑到埃尔娜的个性，这会对她更有效。
I decided that she's going to have to live with this. She knows that she did it. She knows that she hurt her little sister. She knows the truth. And so she's going to live with that for the rest of her life.
我决定让她自己去承受。她知道是她干的。她知道她伤害了自己的小妹妹。她知道真相。所以她这辈子都得背负着这个真相生活下去。
And you thought that would be better than just spanking her?
你觉得这比打她一顿要好吗？
Well, because the spanking would be just a temporary thing, a little smack on the behind.
嗯，因为打屁股只是暂时的，屁股上的一点疼而已。
Obviously, it worked. Her regret over that whole incident-- she still feels it. And lots of other regret about Julia, also. Not long ago, Julia had a baby. And Elna and she are close now. And Elna says she's spent 15 years apologizing to Julia. And she says Julia's baby looks just like how Julia looked as a baby.
显然，这奏效了。她对那整件事的悔恨——她依然能感觉到。还有关于朱莉娅的其他许多悔恨。不久前，朱莉娅生了孩子。埃尔娜和她现在关系很亲近。埃尔娜说她花了15年时间向朱莉娅道歉。她说朱莉娅的宝宝长得就像朱莉娅小时候的样子。
And I would hold the baby and look at her, and she's so beautiful and so delicate. But it made me remember holding and seeing Julia when she was a baby, and how much I hated Julia as a baby. Like, I hated that baby.
我会抱着那个宝宝看着她，她非常漂亮，非常娇嫩。但这让我想起抱着和看着朱莉娅小时候的样子，我当时有多么讨厌朱莉娅这个婴儿。我是真的很讨厌那个宝宝。
And in my mind, I thought, uh, the feeling's mutual. Like, I thought the baby hated me, and I hated the-- we just never got along, me and that baby. It's a baby. The baby had no opinion about anything.
我在心里想，呃，这感情是相互的。我觉得那个宝宝讨厌我，我也讨厌她——我和那个宝宝一直相处不来。这只是个婴儿。那个宝宝对任何事情都没有意见。
So it wasn't just the things that Elna did to Julia that were painful to think about. It was also-- what does this say about me that I felt this way about her, and that I did this to her? And how much have I changed?
所以不仅埃尔娜对朱莉娅做过的事情想起来很痛苦。还有——这件事反映出我是一个怎样的人，我竟然会有这种感觉，竟然会对她做出这种事？我改变了多少？
And Julia's moved on, and the rest of the family's moved on. They joke about how Elna used to treat Julia. Recently, Julia found an old workbook that she did, back when she was a Brownie-- in Girl Scouts, back in third grade.
朱莉娅已经走出来了，家里其他人也走出来了。他们开玩笑说埃尔娜以前是怎么对待朱莉娅的。最近，朱莉娅发现了一本她小时候做过的练习册，那是她当幼女童军时，三年级做的。
And there's this one page--
其中有一页——
And the top of the page says, I wonder. And then, I wonder why, I wonder who, I wonder when. And you have to fill in the blanks.
页顶写着：我很好奇。然后，我好奇为什么，我好奇谁，我好奇何时。你需要填空。
These are very general questions. OK, yeah?
这些是很笼统的问题。噢，是吗？
And this is what Julia says. I wonder why Elna is so mean to me. I wonder if anyone likes me. I wonder whether my sister loves me. I wonder how come Elna doesn't like me. I wonder where I could be happy.
这是朱莉娅写的。我很好奇埃尔娜为什么对我那么刻薄。我很好奇是否有人喜欢我。我很好奇姐姐是否爱我。我很好奇为什么埃尔娜不喜欢我。我很好奇在哪里我才能快乐。
You were awful.
你当时真是太糟糕了。
I was awful. And she read it-- the whole family, everyone was laughing, everyone thought it was really funny. But I actually had to leave the room. I just felt really bad. And I still feel really bad about it.
我是很糟糕。她读出来时——全家人都在笑，每个人都觉得这很好笑。但我必须离开房间。我真的觉得很难受。到现在我对那件事依然感觉很糟糕。
Some regrets just never go away, you know. People tell us that they forgive us. We try to forgive ourselves. And we still know, we did wrong. We hurt somebody. It was real. And that feeling, it can immobilize you. If you're lucky, it teaches you something that you take into other situations.
有些悔恨是永远不会消散的，你知道的。人们告诉我们他们原谅了我们。我们试着原谅自己。但我们依然知道，我们做错了。我们伤害了别人。这是真实的。那种感觉会让你感到瘫痪。如果你足够幸运，它会教会你一些带入到其他境遇中的东西。
But I think, often, it's just like this pebble in your shoe that teaches you nothing. It doesn't slow you down, really. It just hurts. It just hurts in this way that does not stop hurting.
但我认为，通常它就像鞋里的一颗鹅卵石，什么也教不了你。它真的不会拖慢你的脚步。它只会痛。它会以一种不会停止疼痛的方式一直痛着。
And today on our radio show, it is all about regret. We're taking the title of today's episode from an old Frank Sinatra song.
今天在我们的广播节目中，主题全是关于悔恨。我们从弗兰克·辛纳屈的一首老歌中选取了今天这集的主题。
[MUSIC - "MY WAY" BY FRANK SINATRA]
[音乐 - 弗兰克·辛纳屈的《My Way》]
(SINGING) Regrets, I've had a few.
（歌唱）悔恨，我有过一些。
This, of course, is from the song, "My Way." It's a song, I should say, I have never liked, except for that one line.
这当然出自歌曲《My Way》。我得说，除了这句歌词，我从来都不喜欢这首歌。
(SINGING) Regrets, regrets, I've had a few.
（歌唱）悔恨，悔恨，我有过一些。
No matter who sings that line-- Aretha Franklin, Pavarotti--
不管是谁在唱这一句——艾瑞莎·富兰克林，帕瓦罗蒂——
(SINGING) Regrets, I've had a few.
（歌唱）悔恨，我有过一些。
That line always stands out in this bombastic, ridiculous song as the one sincere thought in the song. Though "My Way" is such a crap song that the line right after "Regrets, I've had a few" basically obliterates any sincere feeling of regret. It kills the one sincere moment in the song.
这一句在这首夸夸其谈、荒谬的歌里总是显得格外突出，是歌中唯一真诚的思考。尽管《My Way》是一首垃圾歌曲，以至于“悔恨，我有过一些”后面那句歌词基本上抹杀了任何真诚的悔恨感。它扼杀了歌中唯一真诚的时刻。
(SINGING) I've had a few. But then again, too few to mention.
（歌唱）我有过一些。但话又说回来，太少不值一提。
Oh, really? Too few to mention? Not me, buddy. Not most people. If you don't have regrets, it means you haven't screwed up. It means you haven't had your heart broken. It means you haven't been bloodied. It means you haven't failed, you haven't failed. Like, why even live? Why even live a life?
噢，真的吗？太少不值一提？我不这么看，伙计。大多数人也不是。如果你没有悔恨，意味着你没搞砸过什么。意味着你没经历过心碎。意味着你没受过伤。意味着你没失败过。就像，为什么还要活着？为什么还要过这一生？
Today on our show, we live a life that's full. We travel each and every byway. At least, each and every byway that is full of regret. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目里，我们过着充满的一生。我们走遍每一条路。至少，每一条充满悔恨的小路。来自芝加哥WBEZ，《这是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
(SINGING) Much more than this, I did it--
（歌唱）不仅如此，我做到了——
[MUSIC SLOWS AND DISTORTS]
[音乐放慢并扭曲]
Act One, Tattoos and Memories and Dead Skin on Trial. So if you're going to do a regrets show, why not start with a classic. Right? A classic regret. This story is about a tattoo that a guy decided he was not happy with anymore.
第一幕，纹身、记忆和死皮的审判。所以，如果你要做一期关于悔恨的节目，为什么不从经典开始呢？对吧？一个经典的悔恨故事。这个故事关于一个家伙对他纹的某个纹身不再满意了。
If you're listening to our program on the podcast or on the internet, I just want to give you a heads up. There's cursing in here that we have not beeped. If you prefer a beeped version of our program, you can hear that at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
如果你是在播客或互联网上收听我们的节目，我要先提醒一下。节目中有我们没有消音的脏话。如果你更喜欢消音版，可以在我们的网站thisamericanlife.org收听。
The story was put together by Emily Hsiao, with original music by Merel van Dijk and Anthony Barilla.
这个故事由艾米丽·萧制作，原创音乐由梅瑞尔·范·迪克和安东尼·巴里拉创作。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello? Hi, Hannah! Muffin, how you doing? Geez, I haven't heard from you in a while.
喂？嗨，汉娜！宝贝，你好吗？天哪，好久没收到你的消息了。
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
How you been?
最近怎么样？
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Actually, I'm with this girl Emily right now that's interviewing me. She's a fucking college kid or something. She's interviewing me.
其实，我正和这个叫艾米丽的女孩在一起，她在采访我。她是个他妈的大学生还是什么的。她在采访我。
For what?
采访什么？
I don't know. She does a radio thing or something. She saw I have a ad in Craigslist about getting rid of the swastika tattoo I got. She wanted to know about that. So now she's all curious about prison.
不知道。她搞什么广播节目的。她看到我在Craigslist上登了个广告，想去掉我纹的那个纳粹党徽纹身。她想知道关于那个的事。所以现在她对监狱很感兴趣。
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
24. I'm not doing that. What the fuck is wrong with you? I'm taking her home right now.
24岁。我不干那事儿。你他妈到底怎么回事？我马上就要送她回家了。
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
[LOUD BEEPING SOUND]
[尖锐的哔哔声]
Whenever you're ready.
随时都可以开始。
I'm ready.
我准备好了。
I have to ask to turn the radio off because it's going to be distracting. And eventually after you smoke, if we could close the window?
我得请你关掉收音机，因为它会让人分心。等会儿你抽完烟，我们能关上窗户吗？
Jesus Christ. Is this going to be a trying experience?
我的老天。这会是一次令人痛苦的经历吗？
Uh, only if you make it a trying experience. I think it should be relatively painless. Relatively painless. All righty. Let's start with the basics. Can you tell me a little bit about yourself?
呃，只有如果你把它弄成令人痛苦的经历。我觉得应该相对轻松。相对轻松。好了。我们从基础开始。能简单介绍一下你自己吗？
I'm Bruce Roderick from Centerville. I was born in Provincetown-- 1951, to Portuguese parents. And I moved to Yarmouth in 1964. And what else?
我是森特维尔的布鲁斯·罗德里克。我出生于普罗温斯顿——1951年，父母是葡萄牙人。我1964年搬到了雅茅斯。还有什么？
Keep going. Just start from the top.
继续。从头开始就行。
What do you want me to say?
你想要我说什么？
I don't know, what were you going to say?
我不知道，你本来想说什么？
I thought you were here to look at my tattoo. I have a small swastika tattoo on my left arm that I wish to have covered up. I cannot afford to pay what a tattoo shop is charging. It is only on  a one square inch area.
我以为你是来找我看我的纹身的。我左臂上有一个小的纳粹党徽纹身，我想把它遮盖掉。我付不起纹身店收费的价格。它只有一平方英寸大。
Please, if you do tats on your own, call me or text me. I just want it covered up, blacked out. Nothing fancy. I did it when I was young and I want it off.
求你了，如果你自己能做纹身，打电话或发短信给我。我只想把它遮盖，涂黑。不需要什么花样。我年轻时纹的，现在想把它弄掉。
I just started using drugs when I was 15. Summer kids coming down from New York in Provincetown. They being little rich kids, private schools, they were already using drugs, and they'd bring that shit down.
我15岁时就开始用药了。夏天有从纽约来普罗温斯顿的孩子们。他们是些小富家子弟，上私立学校，已经在用药了，他们把那些垃圾带到了这儿。
And the town kids would get around them, and we'd start using it. Sniffing glue, smoking pot, taking pills. And then it just progressed to other things.
镇上的孩子会围着他们转，我们也开始用了。吸胶水、抽大麻、吃药丸。然后就发展到了别的东西。
I started using heroin, which I liked more than anything. I just continued-- since that day, I've always done heroin. I don't do anything else. I dropped out of school when I was 16. Worked a little bit. Then I started getting in trouble, and was a runaway living the streets of Boston. And started going to prison when I was 17.
我开始使用海洛因，那是我最喜欢的。从那天起，我就一直没断过海洛因。除了这个我什么都不干。我16岁辍学。工作了一阵子。然后我开始惹麻烦，成了波士顿街头的流浪儿。17岁开始进监狱。
What was it for?
因为什么进去的？
That was for a shooting and-- so on drugs. Summer of '69, I believe-- '69, yeah. I was going to go to Woodstock, I got arrested that weekend. I received three year sentence. I made parole, I was out for a month, I went back then. And then I started robbing drug dealers.
是因为一场枪击案和……关于毒品。大概是69年的夏天吧——69年，没错。我本来要去参加伍德斯托克音乐节，结果那个周末我被逮捕了。我被判了三年。我获得了假释，出来一个月，然后又回去了。然后我开始抢劫毒贩。
Wow. What was robbing drug dealers like? How'd you do that?
哇。抢劫毒贩是什么样的？你怎么做到的？
I would knock on the door, they would open the door, I'd put a gun in their face, go into the house, and take the drugs.
我会敲门，他们会开门，我用枪指着他们的脸，进入屋里，拿走毒品。
Have you ever killed anyone?
你杀过人吗？
No. Why would I sit here and admit to something like that anyway, if I did?
没有。再说，如果我杀了人，我干嘛还要坐在这儿承认那种事呢？
Yeah, good question.
没错，好问题。
Right?
对吧？
I was robbing drug dealers, and that was my career right up until 1985, when I went to a house. I went into a house in Centerville, and it was-- police were in the house. They posed as drug dealers.
我一直在抢劫毒贩，那是我的职业，直到1985年，我去了一所房子。我走进森特维尔的一所房子，里面……警察就在屋里。他们伪装成毒贩。
And there was a confrontation in the house I ended up going to prison for. I spent 12 years in jail on that one. Went back in again for selling heroin. Got out, went back in again for selling heroin. Now I just got out again. Now here I am, I been out two years. Almost three years.
屋里发生了对峙，我最后因此进了监狱。我在那次案件中坐了12年牢。又因为卖海洛因进去。出来后，又因为卖海洛因进去。现在我刚出来。这就是我了，我已经出来两年了。快三年了。
This is the longest that I've been out here free and haven't been using.
这是我出来自由生活且没用药最长的一次。
What's prison like?
监狱是什么样的？
What's it like? Prison is very-- there's racial alliances. You have to hang with your own kind. And if you let a black or a Spanish or somebody else not of your race to take advantage of you sexually or whatever, then you become a punk, I guess-- you want some gum?
是什么样的？监狱里非常……有种族联盟。你必须和自己种族的人待在一起。如果你让黑人或西班牙裔或者其他非你种族的人在性等方面占你便宜，那你就会变成一个“小混混”，我猜——你想吃口香糖吗？
Which means anybody can take whatever they want from you, because you didn't stick up for yourself. You're fair game. I think I even got some pictures here.
这意味着任何人都可以从你身上拿走任何东西，因为你没为自己挺身而出。你是被任意宰割的猎物。我想我这儿甚至有几张照片。
Pictures from prison?
监狱的照片？
Yeah, I got a couple, I think. That's me when I was younger. I was a jailbird. That's my niece, my niece. That's me in a bar in Boston. That's a jail picture.
是啊，我想我有几张。那是年轻时的我。我当时是个囚犯。这是我侄女。那是波士顿一家酒吧里的我。那是一张监狱照。
That was my father. That's me in my mother's house. My parents were devastated. No one in my family's ever gotten in trouble before. But they always stuck by me.
那是我的父亲。那是母亲家里的我。我的父母当时非常崩溃。我们家没人惹过麻烦。但他们一直支持我。
Do you think your parents should have practiced tougher love?
你觉得你父母应该对你进行更严厉的管教吗？
What, beat me more? What's tough love? They didn't say, yeah, yeah, here's $20, go get high-- no. My father was disgusted by my behavior. My mother was heartbroken. I my mother's favorite.
什么，多打我几下？什么叫严厉的管教？他们没说过，好的好的，给你20美元，去爽一把——不。我父亲对我的行为感到厌恶。我母亲心碎了。我是母亲最疼爱的。
Of course not, they didn't want me to do the things that I did. Well, you know, what are you going to do? You don't think of nothing else but yourself when you're doing those things you do.
当然不是，他们不想让我做我做的那些事。嗯，你知道，你能怎么样呢？当你做那些事的时候，你脑子里想的只有你自己。
This is North Fork Prison here. That's me there. That's one of my good friends. He's a dope fiend. This guy hung around for like 10 years, right? And he was like my best friend, and I didn't know he was in for rape. And that's prison.
这是北福克监狱。那是那时的我。那是我一个好朋友。他是个毒瘾君子。这家伙待了大概10年吧？他曾经是我最好的朋友，但我不知道他是因为强奸入狱的。这就是监狱。
Whoa. I haven't even gotten to your tattoo yet. I've just been so enthralled.
哇。我还没谈到你的纹身呢。我只是太着迷了。
There's the tattoo. See it? It's not even that big, you can barely even see it. And I got it done around 1986, '87. It was supposed to have white power.
这就是纹身。看到了吗？它甚至没那么大，你几乎都看不见。我大概在86年、87年纹的。本来是为了展示“白人力量”。
I was covering up a question mark I had right there when I was a kid. And this guy, Willie Durette, he did a lot of my tattoos. I think he was in my cell doing a tattoo for somebody else. And I had some biker book or something. When I saw that tattoo, I asked Willie if he could cover the question mark up a bit.
当时我想遮盖小时候纹的一个问号。那个叫威利·杜雷特的家伙帮我做了很多纹身。我想当时他在我的牢房里帮别人纹身。我手里有一本机车杂志之类的。看到那个纹身时，我问威利能不能帮我遮盖一下那个问号。
And I put that on, and now I want this covered up. That's all I want, is that blacked out.
然后我就纹了那个，现在我想把它遮盖掉。我只想要那个，把它涂黑。
Did your buddies get swastikas as well?
你那些哥们儿也纹了纳粹党徽吗？
Oh yeah, most of the white guys back then had swastikas. Swastikas are SWP-- Supreme White Power. FTW-- a lot of them had that. That used to be another big one. Fuck the world.
哦，是的，当时大多数白人家伙都有纳粹党徽。纳粹党徽意味着SWP——至高无上的白人力量。FTW——很多人纹了那个。那曾经是另一个大热门。去他妈的世界（Fuck the world）。
Did the swastika represent Nazi ideas in prison?
在监狱里，纳粹党徽代表纳粹思想吗？
No, it doesn't represent nothing. It's just a fucking tattoo. I don't have anything against Jewish people.
不，它什么也不代表。那只是个该死的纹身。我对犹太人没什么成见。
But that symbol, the swastika, says otherwise, right?
但纳粹党徽那个符号说明的情况相反吧？
The swastika was just a symbol, period.
纳粹党徽只是个符号，仅此而已。
What does it mean to you?
它对你意味着什么？
I like the way it looks. I used to have a big flag. Above my wall, I had a big swastika flag. I gave it to my roommate up in Revere before I moved out.
我喜欢它看起来的样子。我曾经有一面大旗。墙上方，我挂着一面纳粹党徽大旗。我搬走之前把它送给了我在里维尔的室友。
But you know that it carries so many connotations?
但你知道它承载着许多内涵吧？
That's exactly why I'm taking it off my arm. I read an obituary about this Jewish guy that was in the camps. And this guy worked in the gas chambers, the showers.
那正是我想把它从胳膊上弄掉的原因。我读了一篇关于那个在集中营里的犹太人的讣告。那个家伙在毒气室、淋浴房工作。
They would take the bodies out of the shower and bring them to be burned. This guy, that was his job. That's why he was able to survive. He was in there towards the end of the war.
他们会把尸体从淋浴房拖出来带去焚烧。那个家伙，那就是他的工作。这就是他能活下来的原因。他在战争快结束时待在里面。
But anyway, he just died recently. And in his obituary, it said he had written this book. And I read the book. And then, I just didn't want the tattoo anymore. Because it's a very offensive thing.
但总之，他最近刚去世。在他的讣告里，说他写了这本书。我读了那本书。然后，我就不想再要这个纹身了。因为它是一件非常冒犯的东西。
And I am getting older. I don't want to die and have God see that on my arm.
而且我年纪大了。我不想死的时候上帝在我的胳膊上看到那个东西。
I spent over 30 years in prison. I'd like to have those years back. I never had any kids. My mother and father are both dead. They never saw me succeed in nothing. I'm 61, I don't have shit for money.
我在监狱里度过了30多年。我真想把那些岁月找回来。我从来没生过孩子。我的母亲和父亲都去世了。他们从未见我成功过任何事情。我已经61岁了，钱一点也没有。
All of a sudden, I woke up and I was 60 years old. It just flew by. The time flew right by, all behind drugs. And that's it. Are we done?
突然之间，我醒来发现自己已经60岁了。时间飞逝。时间就在毒品中飞逝而去。就是这样。我们要结束了吗？
No.
没有。
Yeah, we are.
是的，我们要结束了。
We are?
我们结束了吗？
Basically, yeah.
基本上是这样。
I'm sorry.
我很抱歉。
But where are you going? Where do you have to go? I'll give you a ride, I'm saying. This interview is over. I'm sorry.
但你要去哪儿？你必须去哪儿？我是说，我可以载你一程。这个采访结束了。我很抱歉。
That's OK.
没关系。
Did it go all right?
还顺利吗？
Yeah.
是的。
We gotta defrost. All right. What did you think, I'm a dirty racist?
我们得解冻了。好了。你以为我是个肮脏的种族主义者？
I didn't know.
我不知道。
What do you think now? Still that dirty racist? You still got that fucking thing on?
你现在怎么想？还是那个肮脏的种族主义者？你身上还有那该死的东西？
Yeah. I do. Right on.
是的。我有。没错。
All right. You gotta get out of here.
好吧。你得离开这儿。
OK, thanks.
好的，谢谢。
My patience is wearing thin.
我的耐心快磨没了。
Thanks, Bruce.
谢谢你，布鲁斯。
Have fun.
玩得开心。
Take care.
保重。
You better say I'm a nice fucking guy in this.
你最好在节目里说我是个他妈的好人。
All righty. Thank you so much.
没问题。非常感谢。
What's up, [INAUDIBLE]. Why the fuck didn't you go pick up Charlie that day? He is so fucking pissed.
怎么了，[听不清]。你他妈那天为什么没去接查理？他他妈气疯了。
That story by Emily Hsiao-- it's one of the very first radio stories she's ever made. She created it at something called the Transom Story Workshop, which takes people who have never done radio-- in eight weeks, it trains them to make stories in Woods Hole, Massachusetts. You can Google Transom Story Workshop, if you're curious about that.
艾米丽·萧做的那个故事——这是她制作的第一批广播故事之一。她在Transom故事研讨会创造了这个故事，该研讨会招收从未做过广播的人——在马萨诸塞州伍兹霍尔，用八周时间培训他们制作故事。如果你对此感到好奇，可以去谷歌搜索Transom Story Workshop。
The music was created for the story by Merel van Dijk and Anthony Barilla from the band Merel & Tony. You can find other music of theirs on SoundCloud-- Merel and Tony.
音乐由梅瑞尔与托尼乐队的梅瑞尔·范·迪克和安东尼·巴里拉为故事创作。你可以在SoundCloud上找到他们的其他音乐——Merel and Tony。
We first aired this story back in 2014. Since then, Bruce found somebody to black out his tattoo.
我们第一次播出这个故事是在2014年。从那时起，布鲁斯找到了遮盖纹身的人。
[MUSIC - "REGRET" BY ST. VINCENT]
[音乐 - 圣文森特的《Regret》]
Coming up, a story with original songs by Stephin Merritt. I'll explain what that's about after the break. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，是一个由斯蒂芬·梅里特创作原创歌曲的故事。休息之后我会解释那是什么情况。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播，我们的节目继续。
This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. On today's show, our theme, of course--
《这是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周在我们的节目中，我们会选择一个主题，带给你关于该主题的不同故事。在今天的节目中，我们的主题，当然——
(SINGING) Regrets, I've had a few.
（歌唱）悔恨，我有过一些。
That's right. Stories of regret. We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two-- This is Just as Hard for Me as It is for You.
没错。悔恨的故事。我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕——这对我来说和你一样难。
One of the most basic parts of being a parent is trying to sort through a bunch of options and figure out what is going to be best for your kids. Everything from what foods they should eat to where you're going to live so they'll have decent schools.
为人父母最基本的部分之一就是试着梳理一大堆选择，并弄清楚什么对孩子最好。从他们应该吃什么食物，到你打算住哪儿好让他们有像样的学校。
This next story is about a father trying to do that, trying to figure out what's best for his children, and having some regrets about how things worked out. His name is Will Ream. And the choices Will has had to make have been pretty dramatic ones.
下一个故事关于一个试图这样做的父亲，试着弄清楚什么对孩子最好，并且对事情的结局感到一些悔恨。他的名字叫威尔·里姆。而威尔不得不做出的选择是非常戏剧性的。
And to tell a story, we're going to try something that we have never attempted before. We asked a songwriter, a great songwriter-- Stephin Merritt, from the band The Magnetic Fields, and other bands also-- to collaborate with us.
为了讲述这个故事，我们将尝试以前从未尝试过的事情。我们邀请了一位伟大的词曲作者——来自Magnetic Fields乐队和其他乐队的斯蒂芬·梅里特——与我们合作。
And mostly, as you'll hear, Stephin has composed music that's going to run underneath the narration and the quotes, like we always have in our stories. Like the music that we had written for Act One of our show today. Though in a couple places-- and really, it's just a few places-- Stephin wrote songs. Like, real songs, with words, that he'll sing.
而且正如你将听到的，斯蒂芬创作的音乐主要会在叙述和语录下方流淌，就像我们在故事里一直做的那样。就像我们在今天节目第一幕中创作的音乐。不过在几个地方——实际上，只是几个地方——斯蒂芬写了歌。就像，真正的歌曲，有歌词，由他演唱。
(SINGING) I'll sing something that sounds like this.
（歌唱）我会唱些听起来像这样的歌。
So during the story that you're about to hear, when Stephin is singing, he's going to be singing things that the dad in the story, Will Ream, actually said. The lyrics are all verbatim quotes. Or they're as close to it as Stephin could get within the structure of a song.
所以，在接下来你将听到的故事中，当斯蒂芬唱歌时，他唱的内容正是故事里的父亲威尔·里姆所说的话。歌词全是原文引用。或者是在歌曲结构下斯蒂芬能做到的尽可能接近的引用。
One of our producers, Miki Meek, first encountered Will Ream when Will Ream had just left everything he had ever known. He had grown up in this incredibly isolated town called Colorado City, in the deserts of northern Arizona.
我们的一位制片人，米基·米克，第一次遇到威尔·里姆时，威尔·里姆刚离开他所知的一切。他在这个难以置信的孤立小镇科罗拉多城长大，位于亚利桑那州北部的沙漠中。
He'd been raised inside this religious group there-- a fundamentalist group, a whole community of people that had split off from the mainstream Mormon church over a century ago. Has lived out there in Colorado City in the desert since. So here is the story. Here's Miki.
他在那里被一个宗教团体抚养长大——一个原教旨主义团体，整个社区的人在一百多年前就脱离了主流摩门教。一直生活在沙漠里的科罗拉多城。这就是故事。这是米基。
So when I first met Will in 2012, he was living in a rundown house outside of Salt Lake City, sleeping on a mattress on the floor, and just trying to figure out how to start his life over.
所以，当我2012年第一次见到威尔时，他住在盐湖城外一栋破旧的房子里，睡在地板上的床垫上，正试图弄清楚如何重新开始他的生活。
He wasn't even sure how he'd gotten to this point, because three years earlier, he was a married man living in Colorado City. He and his wife had four girls and a little boy, and they were surrounded by family and people he'd gone to church with his whole life. He was happy.
他甚至不确定自己是怎么走到这一步的，因为三年前，他还是个住在科罗拉多城的已婚男人。他和妻子有四个女儿和一个小男孩，周围都是家人和他一生一起去教堂的人。他当时很幸福。
But then things started getting strange at church. Church leaders went into this weird paranoid mode, seeing outside threats everywhere, and in everything. And they began to ask Will and some other men to do all sorts of stuff they hadn't asked for before.
但后来教堂里的事情开始变得奇怪起来。教堂领袖进入了一种奇怪的偏执状态，看到处都是外部威胁，在任何事情中都看到威胁。他们开始要求威尔和其他一些男人做各种他们以前从未要求过的事情。
The church leadership had people it wanted to intimidate. These were former church members, and people who were questioning them. So they'd send Will and these other guys from church out in the middle of the night to vandalize these people's stuff-- disable farm equipment, change locks on gates.
教堂领导层有一些想要恐吓的人。这些人是前教堂成员，以及质疑他们的人。所以他们会派威尔和教堂里的这些人深夜出去破坏这些人的东西——拆除农具，更换门锁。
And the church told Will and the other men-- you can't tell your wives.
教堂告诉威尔和其他男人——你们不能告诉你们的妻子。
My gut reaction was if I am married to her, then we are supposed to be as one. So why am I supposed to keep secrets from her? Because it seems to me like that would be detrimental to our relationship.
我的本能反应是如果我跟她结婚了，那么我们应该成为一体。所以我为什么要对她保守秘密呢？因为在我看来这会对我们的关系有害。
Did you ask that? Did you feel like you could ask that?
你问过吗？你觉得你能问吗？
I couldn't ask that.
我不能问。
That's just not something that was done?
那根本就不是能做的事情？
No. That wasn't something we did.
不。那不是我们做的事情。
Will says, he felt like he and his wife had a good marriage, that they were close. And now here he was, leaving in the middle of the night and staying out for hours, and not telling her why.
威尔说，他觉得自己和妻子婚姻美满，他们很亲近。而现在，他不得不深夜离家，待上好几个小时，却不告诉她原因。
Church leaders told Will, you don't owe her an explanation. If she wants answers, she should pray harder. Even for a young religious wife who was used to a man being the final word, this was too much. It dragged on for almost a year.
教堂领袖告诉威尔，你不需要向她解释。如果她想要答案，她应该更努力地祈祷。即使对于一个习惯于男人拥有最终决定权的年轻宗教妻子来说，这也太过分了。这持续了将近一年。
She would say, like, what were you guys doing last night? And I would say, I can't tell you. Or, a man doesn't need to tell his wife everything. And I would use that line that they told me, which, now-- even just now, when I said it, it makes me go tense. That's something that hurts, that I was that stupid.
她会说，你们昨晚在做什么？我会说，我不能告诉你。或者，男人不需要告诉妻子每件事。我会用他们教我的那句话，现在——甚至刚才，当我说了那句话时，它都让我感到紧张。那是一件伤害人的事，我当时竟然那么蠢。
And there were quite a few nights where I remember she would be really distraught. And she would go into the bathroom, into the shower, and just weep it out. And I would turn my back on her. And force myself to not feel.
有几个晚上我记得她非常痛苦。她会走进浴室，进入淋浴间，只是哭出来。而我背对着她。强迫自己不去感受。
If there was anything I could ever do to take that back, I would have. But I drove her to a place where she was very depressed, and very hurt, because she loved me with all her heart.
如果我能做任何事来挽回那一切，我会的。但我把她带到了一个她非常抑郁，非常受伤的地方，因为她全心全意地爱我。
If I'd known at that point what I was choosing at that point, if I was choosing her or the church, I would have chosen her. But I didn't even realize it was really that big of a problem at that point.
如果我在那时候知道我正在做出什么选择，如果是在她和教会之间做选择，我会选择她的。但我当时甚至没意识到那是个大问题。
One day Will came home from work and his wife was gone. She left him a note saying she needed to think. He tried to work it out with her for a year and a half after that. She even moved back home for a while.
有一天威尔下班回家，发现妻子不见了。她给他留了一张纸条，说她需要思考。在那之后，他试着挽回了一年半。她甚至搬回来住了一阵子。
But in the end, Will says she wanted nothing to do with her old life. She didn't want to be a mom or a wife, and she checked out on Will and their five kids. She wouldn't talk to me for this story.
但最终，威尔说她不想再跟以前的生活有任何牵连。她不想当妈妈或妻子，她丢下了威尔和他们的五个孩子。她不愿意和我谈这个故事。
But Will says they had gotten married when she was 15. So when she left him, she was still in her early 20s. She had never experienced anything outside the church. Now she started seeing other men, and drinking.
但威尔说他们结婚时她才15岁。所以当她离开他时，她才20出头。她从未体验过教会之外的任何东西。现在她开始见其他男人，喝酒。
Will was devastated, and he resented the church for causing their breakup. And things were getting even weirder at church.
威尔崩溃了，他憎恨教会导致了他们的分手。而且教堂里的情况变得更诡异了。
Will's particular branch of fundamentalist Mormonism is headed by the Prophet Warren Jeffs. You may have heard of him. He got investigated in Utah, Arizona, and Texas for sexual assault and marrying underage girls. He was sentenced to life in prison.
威尔所在的那个原教旨主义摩门教分支由先知沃伦·杰夫斯领导。你可能听说过他。他在犹他州、亚利桑那州和得克萨斯州因性侵和与未成年女孩结婚受到调查。他被判处终身监禁。
Will and the other followers were told if they had enough faith, God would release Jeffs from prison. And so to test their faith, lots of strange new rules came down. Don't eat sugar. Only wear homemade clothing-- and it can't be the color red.
威尔和其他追随者被告知，只要他们有足够的信心，上帝就会把杰夫斯从监狱里释放出来。因此为了考验他们的信心，发布了许多奇怪的新规则。不要吃糖。只能穿自制的衣服——而且不能是红色的。
Will remembers one Sunday, a new set of rules came down, specifically aimed at everyone's kids.
威尔记得一个周日，发布了一套新规则，专门针对所有人的孩子。
They talked about how the kids weren't supposed to play. I think that was probably one of the biggest things for me, was they weren't supposed to play just to have fun anymore. They were asking the people to get rid of their children's toys, and to not allow them to ride their bicycles.
他们谈到孩子们不应该玩耍。我想那大概是对我来说最大的事情之一，他们不再被允许为了开心而玩耍了。他们要求人们处理掉孩子的玩具，并且不准他们骑自行车。
They basically were saying that we needed to sacrifice everything that meant anything to us. Everything from our desires to our physical belongings to our homes to our families to everything. We needed to be willing to sacrifice everything for the good of the prophet.
他们基本上是在说，我们需要牺牲掉对我们意味着一切的东西。从我们的欲望到我们的实物财产，到我们的家，到我们的家人，到一切。为了先知的好处，我们必须愿意牺牲一切。
I just remember leaving that place feeling like shit, thinking, is this really what I want? Is this really what I want for my kids?
我只记得离开那里时感觉糟糕透了，心想，这真的是我想要的吗？这真的是我为我的孩子们想要的吗？
Will got desperate. He reached out to his bishop at church.
威尔绝望了。他联系了教会的主教。
I told him, I says, I need some help here. I'm losing it. And he just says, you need to pray more. You need to get over it. That's all he said-- you need to pray more.
我告诉他，我说，我需要帮助。我快疯了。他只是说，你需要多祈祷。你需要克服它。这就是他说的全部——你需要多祈祷。
And I just thought about that, and I thought, huh. You're turning into what I used-- or you're giving me what I used to give my wife. And there was no life left in me at that point.
我反思了那句话，我想，呵。你变得和我以前一样了——或者说你给了我以前给妻子的东西。在那一点上，我心中已经毫无生机了。
I would walk at 2, 3, 4 o'clock in the morning. All through the night, just pace, walk up in the canyons, walk just everywhere, just trying to get some kind of clarity.
我会凌晨2点、3点、4点走路。整夜整夜地，踱步，走在峡谷里，走在到处，只是为了试图得到某种清晰的认知。
(SINGING) I had this big blank sheet of paper, where I was going to write my reasons to live. Or why not end it all today? And kids was the only reason I could give.
（歌唱）我有一张巨大的白纸，我本打算写下我活下去的理由。或者为什么不今天就结束这一切？而孩子是我能给出的唯一理由。
I felt betrayed by my religion, and by the only person I had ever loved, and opened up to. You bet I felt betrayed.
我感到被我的宗教，以及我曾经爱过并向其敞开心扉的唯一一个人背叛了。你敢打赌我感到被背叛了。
They all said pray. Yeah, well, I prayed. I've had the knife sitting in front of  me. I've had the pills sitting in front of me.
他们都说祈祷。是的，好吧，我祈祷了。刀就放在我面前。药丸就放在我面前。
And I've been sitting right up on the cliff's edge, with one foot dangling off the ledge. And kids was the only reason I could give.
我一直坐在悬崖边上，一只脚悬在崖边。而孩子是我能给出的唯一理由。
They all said pray. Yeah, well, I prayed.
他们都说祈祷。是的，好吧，我祈祷了。
When the church told kids they weren't allowed to play, that was the last straw for Will. He'd already lost his wife, and now his whole life was about trying to make things OK for his kids again. He had a radical thought-- maybe they just had to get out and start over.
当教会告诉孩子们不准玩耍时，那是威尔最后的底线。他已经失去了妻子，而现在他整个生命就是试着让孩子们重新过得好起来。他有一个激进的想法——也许他们必须离开并重新开始。
So on his 33rd birthday, Will loaded his kids into a van, and they headed north. Once they got 20 miles away, he stopped the car and explained to his kids what he was doing.
所以在他的33岁生日那天，威尔把孩子们装进一辆货车，他们向北行驶。一旦他们离开20英里远，他停下车，向孩子们解释他正在做的事情。
I says, we're going to go and make a life for ourselves somewhere else. I asked them how they felt about that. And they all said that they wanted to come and build a new life.
我说，我们要去别的地方为自己创造生活。我问他们对此有什么感觉。他们都说他们想来创造新的生活。
Were you scared at all at that time? Did you doubt yourself at all?
你那时候害怕吗？你怀疑过自己吗？
I wondered. Oh yeah. I really did. I wondered if we were all going to be destroyed tomorrow, and I screwed up. Maybe a week from now.
我怀疑过。哦，是的。我真的怀疑过。我怀疑我们明天会不会都被摧毁，我把事情搞砸了。也许一周之后。
But I actually felt like hope. It was genuine hope for the first time in a long time, that I could give them another shot at life. It was like taking a breath of air after you've had your head under water. You know?
但我真的感觉到了希望。这是很长一段时间以来第一次有真正的希望，我可以给他们另一个生活的机会。就像在把头潜入水底后，呼吸到了一口空气一样。你知道吗？
Will ended up way north in a city called Ogden, not far from Salt Lake. He and his kids moved into a small apartment, and started living among regular people for the first time. Doing stuff regular people do, like going to the movies.
威尔最终向北到达了一个叫奥格登的城市，离盐湖城不远。他和孩子们搬进了一间小公寓，第一次和普通人生活在一起。做普通人做的事情，比如去电影院。
We went and saw Despicable Me , and it was in 3D. And it was the first movie they'd ever seen in their life. And I was watching them jump, bouncing in their seats and giggling and laughing, and jumping backwards when it looked like stuff was coming out of the screen. And I watched them more than I watched the movie.
我们去看了《卑鄙的我》，是3D的。这是他们一生中看过的第一部电影。我看着他们跳起来，在座位上蹦蹦跳跳，咯咯笑，大笑，当看起来东西从屏幕里出来时向后跳。我看着他们的时间比看电影的时间还要多。
And I got to see them be genuinely happy, and not get put in check. And to just be a child. And it was amazing.
我能够看到他们真正快乐，没受到压制。能够只是当一个孩子。这真是太棒了。
The four girls all cut their hair. They painted their nails and got their ears pierced. All of that was forbidden back where they used to live. And for the first time in their lives, they played with kids who weren't fundamentalists.
四个女儿都剪了头发。她们涂了指甲，打了耳洞。这一切在他们过去住的地方都是被禁止的。而且这是她们一生中第一次和不是原教旨主义者的孩子玩。
Back in their old lives, they had names for people like that-- Gentiles, apostates, wicked.
在他们过去的生活中，他们有叫那些人的名字——外邦人（Gentiles），叛教者，邪恶的。
Well, we were at a park in Ogden one time. And they were playing on the swings, and there were some other children there. And one of the other children's mothers came up, and was helping them and stuff.
有一次我们在奥格登的一个公园里。她们在秋千上玩，那里还有其他孩子。其中一个孩子的妈妈走过来，帮了她们之类的。
And I came walking up, and my oldest daughter was like, dad, you know, the wicked people are pretty nice. And the other lady just glared at me. And I was just like, I'm sorry. I didn't really know what to say.
我走过去，大女儿说，爸爸，你知道，邪恶的人人挺好的。另一个女士狠狠瞪了我一眼。我只是说，对不起。我真的不知道该说什么。
You're like shrugging your shoulders.
你耸了耸肩。
Yeah, I didn't really know what to say. And I just says, hon, these people aren't wicked. They're just like us.
是啊，我真的不知道该说什么。我只是说，宝贝，这些人不邪恶。他们和我们一样。
And they would ask me all of the time, so are we apostates now? Are we Gentiles now? So they were concerned about being able to go to heaven. Like, you'd hear them talking about it between themselves.
他们一直问我，所以我们现在是叛教者吗？我们现在是外邦人吗？所以她们很担心能不能上天堂。就像，你会听到她们自己在谈论这个。
They would be like, we went to a movie, and movies are wicked, so we're wicked people. And one of the other ones would say, no, we're not wicked people. That was fun. Dad said it was OK.
她们会说，我们看了电影，电影是邪恶的，所以我们是邪恶的人。其中一个会说，不，我们不是邪恶的人。那很有趣。爸爸说是可以的。
(SINGING) Back in Colorado City, we did not associate with colored people. But in Ogden, it's OK. These two kids who spoke Swahilli-- we all had this barbecue, and my girls loved them. It was just like night and day, seeing my kids play.
（歌唱）回到科罗拉多城，我们不和有色人种交往。但在奥格登，没问题。那两个说斯瓦希里语的孩子——我们举行了烧烤会，我的女儿们很喜欢他们。看到我的孩子们玩耍，简直是天壤之别。
Back in Colorado City, wearing shorts is like rebelling before God. But in Ogden, they don't care, so we wore just what we wanted. Girls went shopping, skirts and dresses, and played music. We could never do that there. Every one would stare.
回到科罗拉多城，穿短裤就像在上帝面前叛逆。但在奥格登，他们不在乎，所以我们穿我们想穿的。女孩子们去购物，买裙子和连衣裙，播放音乐。我们在那里永远做不到那样。每个人都会盯着看。
We couldn't wear red, because maybe that's what Jesus would wear. We couldn't wear anything bought in a store. We couldn't eat sugar, play games. The kids couldn't have toys, or doing anything fun anymore.
我们不能穿红色，因为也许那是耶稣会穿的颜色。我们不能穿任何商店里买的东西。我们不能吃糖，玩游戏。孩子们不再有玩具，也不能做任何有趣的事了。
But in Ogden, we had parties. And the older kids went on roller coasters. And they went and got their hair done.
但在奥格登，我们开了派对。大一点的孩子坐了过山车。她们去做头发。
They had a good summer, a fun summer. But when fall came, it was like reality hit. The kids were going to public school for the first time in their lives. They'd been home-schooled before that.
她们过了一个美好的夏天，一个快乐的夏天。但秋天来临时，现实就像冲击了过来。孩子们有生以来第一次上公立学校。在此之前她们是在家上学的。
And Will decided to go to school, too. He only had an eighth grade education, so he got his GED, and then enrolled as a freshman at the local college.
威尔决定也去上学。他只有八年级教育程度，所以他拿到了GED证书，然后作为大一新生进入了当地大学。
It was incredibly tough for Will, trying to hold everything together, the five kids, by himself. When he left the restrictions of their old life, he also left behind all the love and support that came with it.
对威尔来说这非常艰难，试着独自撑起一切，五个孩子。当他离开旧生活的限制时，他也抛弃了随之而来的所有爱与支持。
For the first time in Will's life, he had no family members, no church members, nobody to come over and watch his kids for a night, or to bring a meal. He'd been living in this tightly knit small town, where everybody looked out for each other, where everybody had known him since he was a kid.
威尔一生中第一次，没有家人，没有教堂成员，没有人能过来帮他看一个晚上的孩子，或者带来一顿饭。他一直生活在这个紧密联系的小镇上，每个人都互相照顾，每个人从他小时候就认识他。
And now, he was far away, and they'd all completely cut him off. One of his sisters called him up one day just to tell him that she'd never talk to him again.
而现在，他远在天边，他们完全切断了与他的联系。他一个姐妹有一天打电话过来只是为了告诉他她永远不会再和他说话了。
Will got increasingly overwhelmed. He couldn't see how things were going to work out. He had no long-term plan for how to support himself and these five children. They were living off his savings, because he was in school.
威尔变得越来越不知所措。他看不出事情会怎样解决。他没有长期计划来支撑自己和这五个孩子。他们靠他的积蓄生活，因为他在上学。
All his energy had gone into figuring out how to get out. And they got out, but now what? One day in class, Will lost it.
他所有的精力都花在了如何离开上。他们离开了，但现在呢？有一天在课堂上，威尔崩溃了。
Just something snapped. I just broke down. I started weeping, and I couldn't stop. It was really hard, and incredibly lonely, when you're 33 years old, to learn how to live again. To basically start from square one.
有什么东西断了。我只是崩溃了。我开始哭泣，无法停止。当你33岁时，学习如何重新生活，简直是从零开始，这真的很艰难，也异常孤独。
Will went home and curled up on the couch for three or four hours, crying. Then he went and picked up his kids from school.
威尔回家蜷缩在沙发上哭了两三个小时。然后他去学校接孩子们。
And then, I started making dinner. And then, it was like I was kind of out of it. And when I came back to, I just started looking around. And I asked my oldest daughter, did you check on the food in the oven?
然后，我开始做晚饭。然后，我感觉自己有点恍惚。当我回过神来，我开始四处张望。我问大女儿，你检查烤箱里的食物了吗？
And she's like, we already ate, Dad. I looked around, and my oldest daughter had gotten the dinner out of the oven, and served the children and fed them. And they were done, and she'd cleared the dishes off the table, and they were sitting in the seat. And I realized it was three hours later. It freaked me out.
她说，我们已经吃过了，爸爸。我环顾四周，大女儿已经把晚餐从烤箱里拿出来，端给孩子们喂饱了。他们吃完了，她把盘子从桌上清理干净，他们坐在位子上。我意识到已经过了三个小时了。我吓坏了。
Will thinks that for three hours, he was just standing in one spot in the kitchen, as his kids walked around him and served themselves dinner. In those three hours, Will could have set fire to the casserole, or the apartment. A lot could have gone wrong.
威尔认为在那三个小时里，他只是呆呆地站在厨房的一个位置，孩子们在他身边走来走去，自己吃饭。在那三个小时里，威尔本可能点燃了砂锅，或者公寓。很多事情可能出错。
Will's only goal at this point in his life was to be a good dad to these kids. Now he felt like he was putting them in real danger. His five kids were all young. The oldest was 11, and the youngest was four. I am not stable, he thought.
威尔此时生活中的唯一目标就是做一个好爸爸。现在他觉得自己在让他们处于真正的危险之中。他的五个孩子都很小。最大的11岁，最小的四岁。我想我并不稳定，他想。
So Will started talking to some counselors. They told him that his situation was serious. He needed to let someone help him care for his kids. So he started looking for help.
所以威尔开始和一些咨询师交谈。他们告诉他情况很严重。他需要让别人帮他照顾孩子。所以他开始寻求帮助。
And within a week, Will's friends-- families he was just getting to know-- agreed to let his kids live with them, just for a little while, just until Will got back on his feet. Will tried to explain this to his kids-- that he wasn't doing so well, that he needed someone to help with them. And then his 11-year-old piped up.
一周之内，威尔的朋友——他刚开始认识的家庭——同意让他们帮他养孩子，只是暂时的，直到威尔重新振作起来。威尔试图向孩子们解释这件事——他现在状态不好，他需要有人帮他。然后11岁的大女儿插话了。
And that's when she says, well, I can, Dad. And it just made me feel worse. And I just told her, I says, I can't allow you to do that. I can't. I says, you need to be a kid.
就在那时她说，爸爸，我可以帮忙。那让我感觉更糟糕。我只是告诉她，我说，我不能让你这么做。我不能。我说，你需要当个孩子。
They didn't understand. I mean, they're just like, well, a week? Do we get to come home next weekend? And it was hard. Because I couldn't give them a period of time. I didn't know.
她们不明白。我的意思是，她们只是觉得，嗯，一周？我们下个周末可以回家吗？这很艰难。因为我无法给出确切的时间。我不知道。
And I was just hoping that somehow, some way, that I would just grow back. That I would be able to, that I'd be able to stand up and take care of it.
我只是希望某种程度上，我会好起来。我会能够，我会能够站起来照顾她们。
That's not what happened, though. What was supposed to be temporary turned into two years. That's when I first talked to Will. He was living in a house with a beat-up couch and a mattress and not a lot more, and doing pretty badly.
但那并没有发生。本应是暂时的却变成了两年。那就是我第一次和威尔谈话的时候。他住在一栋破旧的房子里，有一张破旧的沙发和床垫，几乎没别的东西了，过得相当糟糕。
He'd dropped out of school and taken a construction job to support the family. But it just wasn't enough. He'd spiraled into a depression where all he could do was work and sleep. This is from that first interview.
他退学了，找了一份建筑工作来养家。但这根本不够。他陷入了抑郁，所有能做的只是工作和睡觉。这是第一次采访的内容。
I'll still have some pretty bad lows, some pretty bad days sometimes, where I need to just kind of disappear into the ether and think about things. And it's really hard. Really hard for me to deal with.
我有时仍然会有很严重的低谷，很糟糕的日子，我需要消失在虚空中思考事情。这真的很难。对我来说处理起来真的很难。
I feel like I've failed, kind of. Where I'm not taking care of my kids anymore, my family's not together anymore, stuff like that. It feels like I've had to admit failure, which is hard.
我觉得我某种程度上失败了。我不再照顾孩子了，我的家庭不再完整了，之类的。感觉我不得不承认失败，这很艰难。
But I always identified myself as their dad. But hopefully, I can get into a place where-- I'd really like to be dad again.
但我一直认为自己是她们的爸爸。但希望，我能达到一个地方……我真的想再次成为爸爸。
His daughters were only 20 minutes away, but it was hard for Will to see them. He'd go over and read books and play games with them. And then when he had to leave, they'd always ask, when do we get to come home?
女儿们住在离他只有20分钟车程的地方，但威尔很难见到她们。他会过去读书，和她们玩游戏。然后当他必须离开时，她们总是会问，我们什么时候回家？
Will never had an answer for them. His life was still a mess. And so he'd drive away, feeling totally wrecked that he'd let them down. Will started going to see them less often, because it was so painful. And because it seemed like the more he stayed away, the better they did.
威尔从来没有答案。他的生活依然是一团糟。所以他开车离开时，感到彻底崩溃，因为他让她们失望了。威尔开始减少去看她们的次数，因为那太痛苦了。而且因为看起来他离开得越久，她们过得越好。
Seeing him raised upsetting questions. And when he stayed away, they thrived, settled into their new lives, and made friends. They played soccer, which the girls never would have done, back in their old community in Colorado City. They got to be kids.
见到他引起了令人不安的问题。而当他远离时，她们茁壮成长，在她们的新生活中安定下来，交了朋友。她们踢足球，在科罗拉多城老家时女孩子们是绝不会那样做的。她们能够当孩子了。
And so Will came to a hard, awful conclusion. He needed to let them move on, without the question of coming home always hanging over their heads. And so after they've been living with their new families for two years, Will waived his parental rights. He let the families adopt his kids.
所以威尔得出了一个艰难、可怕的结论。他需要让她们继续前行，不再有关于回家的问题一直挂在心头。所以当她们在寄养家庭生活了两年后，威尔放弃了他的监护权。他让这些家庭收养了他的孩子。
Giving up your kids, you gave them a better life. But it didn't necessarily do that exact thing for you.
放弃你的孩子，你给了她们更好的生活。但这并不一定对你本人有同样的效果。
It didn't do that exact thing for me. But that's OK. I'm fine with that. Because they have what I wanted them to have now. They have what I couldn't give them otherwise.
这对我本人并没有那个效果。但没关系。我对此没意见。因为她们现在有了我想要她们有的东西。她们有了我否则无法给她们的东西。
Will had done what he originally wanted to do when he left Colorado City. He'd given his kids a better life. The girls' adopted mom told me that his daughters now see that's what he intended, that he'd tried to do what was best for them, though it took them a while to see it that way.
威尔做到了他在离开科罗拉多城时最初想要做的事情。他给了孩子们更好的生活。女孩们的收养妈妈告诉我，女儿们现在明白了那是他的初衷，他试着做对她们最好的事，虽然她们花了一段时间才那样看。
It's gotten easier for Will to visit his kids and Skype with them. He used to keep all their photos boxed up. It was too hard to look at them. But now his bedroom shelves are lined with their pictures.
威尔去探望孩子和与她们视频通话变得容易了些。他以前把所有的照片都锁在盒子里。看它们太痛苦了。但现在他卧室的架子上摆满了她们的照片。
The kids' adopted families live farther away now. That's hard. The son is now in southern Utah, and his four daughters are in another state. And so Will took a job driving oil trucks in Texas and North Dakota. The pay was better, and he no longer had a reason to stick around Salt Lake full time.
孩子们收养的家庭现在住得更远了。这很艰难。儿子现在在犹他州南部，四个女儿在另一个州。所以威尔找了一份在得克萨斯州和北达科他州开油罐车的工作。工资更好，他也没有理由继续全职待在盐湖城了。
At each point since leaving Colorado City, Will made what seemed like the best choice for his family. But as a result, he doesn't have a family anymore.
自从离开科罗拉多城以来，威尔在每一个点上都做了对家庭看起来最好的选择。但结果就是，他再也没有家庭了。
I miss them. All day, every day. They've never left my mind. I think about the way they used to laugh. Their little oddities, the weird little things they would say. The way they would walk, when they learned to walk. How long their mom was in labor with them, the way they looked when they were born.
我想她们。整天，每一天。她们从未离开我的脑海。我想起她们过去笑的样子。她们的小怪癖，她们说的奇怪的小事。她们走路的样子，她们学走路的时候。她们妈妈怀她们的时间有多长，她们出生时的样子。
If you could somehow go back in time, would you?
如果你能以某种方式回到过去，你会吗？
If I could go back and have everything that I've experienced been removed from my plate, and just dropped straight back into that, into the same mindset-- I might. It was a good life.
如果我能回到过去，把我所经历的一切从盘子里移除，直接回到那个状态，到同样的心态——我可能会。那是一段美好的生活。
I refer to that point in my life as having everything, back when I had everything. And that was the pinnacle of my life. That was when everything made sense, and I had everything I ever wanted.
我把自己那段生活称为拥有了一切，回到我拥有一切的时候。那是我的生命巅峰。那是所有事情都有意义，我拥有一切我想要东西的时候。
(SINGING) I've lost hope, and I lost my youth. Lost my church and my hold on truth. I lost my health. I can't do nine to five. But I could still drive.
（歌唱）我失去了希望，失去了青春。失去了我的教堂和对真理的掌握。我失去了健康。我干不了朝九晚五。但我还能开车。
I started life again at 33. I hauled my ass to Texas to be me. To save my sanity. I lost my family. All the doors slammed shut.
我33岁时重新开始了生活。我把我的屁股带到得克萨斯做自己。为了保住我的理智。我失去了家人。所有门都关上了。
I know who I am, but I'm not sure what. I did what I had to do to survive. I don't sleep too well, but I can still drive.
我知道我是谁，但我不知道是什么。我做了我必须做的来生存。我睡得不太好，但我还能开车。
Original songs and scoring by Stephin Merritt, with Sam Davol on cello and glockenspiel. Pinky Weitzman on viola. Engineering by Charles Newman. Miki Meek reported this story. Miki is one of the producers of our show.
由斯蒂芬·梅里特创作的原创歌曲和配乐，山姆·达沃尔演奏大提琴和钟琴。平基·魏茨曼演奏中提琴。查尔斯·纽曼工程制作。米基·米克报道了这个故事。米基是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC - "GAME CALLED LIFE" BY LEFTOVER CUTIES]
[音乐 - Leftover Cuties的《Game Called Life》]
Our program was produced today by Chana Joffe-Walt with Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike.
我们的节目今天由Chana Joffe-Walt制作，Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp和Nancy Updike共同参与。
The senior producer for today show's was Julie Snyder. Our editor is Joel Lovell. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Production help from Lilly Sullivan. Seth Lind is our director of operations. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson is our business operation manager.
今天节目的高级制片人是Julie Snyder。我们的编辑是Joel Lovell。我们的技术总监是Matt Tierney。Lilly Sullivan提供了制作帮助。Seth Lind是我们的运营总监。Emily Condon是我们的制作经理。Elise Bergerson是我们的业务运营经理。
Elna Baker scouts stories for the show. Kimberly Henderson is our office coordinator. Research help from Michelle Harris, Christopher Swetala, and Julie Beer. Music help today from Damien Graef.
Elna Baker负责为节目发掘故事。Kimberly Henderson是我们的办公室协调员。Michelle Harris, Christopher Swetala和Julie Beer提供研究帮助。今天Damien Graef提供音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[鸣谢]
In the years since we first ran our story about Will Ream, the guy in the last act-- he's now back in Salt Lake, working a construction job. He says they're all doing well.
自从我们第一次播出关于Will Ream的故事以来，也就是最后一幕里的那个家伙——他现在回到了盐湖城，从事建筑工作。他说他们都过得很好。
Our website-- thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. You know who puts baby in a corner? He is the one who put baby in a corner. Like he always says--
我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org。《这是美国生活》由PRX公共广播交换系统分发到公共广播电台。你知道是谁把“宝宝”放在角落里吗？他就是那个把宝宝放在角落里的人。就像他总是说的——
Like, I hated that baby. And in my mind, I thought, the feeling's mutual.
就像，我讨厌那个宝宝。我在心里想，这感情是相互的。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带给你更多《这是美国生活》的故事。